e
Philippe Leblanc est allé à
Mumbai.
- Mumbai : ville
de contradictions
où les bidonvilles
côtoient les gratte-ciel.
(klaxons)
Mégapole surpeuplée, affligée
par la division des classes,
la pauvreté et la discrimination
contre les femmes.
Ces jeunes viennent de
se réveiller. Comme près
d'un million de personnes,
ils habitent le bidonville
de Dharavi. Ils s'entassent
à huit nsns le petit appartement
suffocant, loué pour
l'équivalent de 130 $ par mois.
(en hindi)
"L'eau potable coule
pour la premrerere fois
en trois jours," ajoute-t-il.
Ils transforment rapidement
l'endroit en mini usine
de textiLeLeLes hommes sont
partis de leur village en quête
d'emplois pour faire vivre
leurs familles.
(en hindi)
Mais le responsable de
cette petite production
peine à payer ses employés.
"Les entreprises se livrent
une concurrence, dit-il.
Elles font ainsi baisser
les prix et les profits
de tous afin de réussir
à trouver un peu de travail."
(klaxons)
C'àààà un des défis de l'Inde:
fournir suffisamment d'emplois
à sa jeune population.
Selon le Centre de surveillance
de l'économie indienne, mêmesist
une forte croissance, à peine
40 % de la population en âge
de travailler réussie e e e faie
ou même souhaite travailler.
Une proportion encore plus
faible chez les ....
Cet analyste préfère imaginer
le potentiel de l'Inde
dans le cas où le pays créerait
davantage d'emplois de qualité.
Une scène familière :
la distribution de repas
gratuits. Dans ce cas-ci,
dans un des hôpitaux publics
de Mumbai.
Les familles de patients, venus
souvent de villages éloignés,
peuvent manger à leur faim
trois fois par jour.
"Grâce à cette aide, dit-il,
je peux me concentrer à aider
ma fille malade. Elle doit venir
suivre des traitements plusieurs
fois par mois pour des problèmes
à l'intestin." L'hôpital est à
16 heures de train de chez lui.
L'organisme sans but lucratif
derrière l'initiative prépare
et livre 15 papapapapapar jour
dans les hôpitaux et écoles
des bidonvilles de Mumbai.
Le financement provient en
grande l l l l l l'entreprise
privée, en vertu de l'obligation
gouvernementale de redonner
2  p p p p p profits à la lutte
contre les problèmes sociaux
de l'Inde. Le fondateur
ananananananisme s'attend
cependant à ce que les groupes
vulnérables continuent
de croître.
Malgré ses inégalités sociales
et problèmes internes
chroniques, l'Inde de Narendra
Modi veut jouer un rôle plus
important sur l'échiquier
mondial.
L'Inde assure cette année
la présidence du G20, essaie
d'étendre son influence
à l'international et devient
maintenant le pays le plus
peuplé de la planète. Au
d'arguments qui renforcent
sa revendication de longue date
d'obtenir un siège permanent au
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Mumba